[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat depuis 2002 les
jeunes papas ont le droit à un congé
paternité de 11 jours trop court pour
certains qui jugent sa durée
insuffisante
plusieurs pétitions et propositions vont
dans ce sens mais le gouvernement botte
en touche
allongé et rendre obligatoire le congé
paternité permettrait-il également une
meilleure égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les hommes c'est le débat
du jour la vie hors toulouse
bonsoir à vous êtes avocate spécialiste
en droit du travail au barreau de
versailles mais vous êtes également
membre de l'association et guînoise très
actif quelques mots pour commencer sur
votre association
c'est une association qui regroupe des
femmes chefs d'entreprise on se réunit
régulièrement on a beaucoup d'événements
en matinée en soirée le but c'est de
fédérer un petit peu nos énergies pour
développer nos activités en face de vous
genres latino bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le président de l'association sos papa
là aussi quelques mots sur votre
association
oui alors je dis tout de suite que je
n'ai pas créé puisqu'elle existe depuis
assez longtemps depuis bientôt 30 ans a
été créée par monsieur d'élever des
yvelines dire michel tison et sur le
principe est le constat qui
malheureusement n'a pas changé c'est à
dire que les papas ont les plus grandes
difficultés à voir leurs enfants en cas
de séparation
mais cela dit nous accueillons
[Musique]
des exceptions qui arrive de temps en
temps des mamans qui elles aussi sont
dans ce genre de difficultés mais dans
des proportions totalement différente
merci en tout cas tous les deux d'être
présent ce soir alors pour commencer un
chiffre en 2013 en france 71 % des pères
ont eu recours aux congés paternité
c'est un chiffre issu de la dernière
étude de la direction de la recherche
des études de l'évaluation et des
statistiques
cette pâture disent qu'ils ont donc eu
rocourt un congé paternité une réaction
jean mach 6 au 7 papa sur dix c'est bien
c'est mieux faire beau franchement bon
c'est un sujet qui nous sommes un petit
peu
éloignée ou décalés pas nouveau en plus
parce qu'en langage journalistique on
peut appeler ça un petit peu à
marronniers parce que j'ai sous les yeux
vous voyez à une interview qui avait
fait de moi le figaro en janvier 2014
donc c'est pas tout à fait neuf
exactement sur le même sujet donc la
situation finalement n'a pas n'a pas
évolué depuis
depuis plusieurs années oui l'or au
niveau des chiffres bons se sait pas ces
chiffres là quand suit de près je
pourrais vous en donner d'autres
extrêmement intéressant rappelait déjà
que le congé paternité en france
aujourd'hui il est de 11 jours pour une
essence simple dix jours en cas de
naissances multiples onze jours qui
peuvent se cumuler donc avec le congé de
naissance de trois jours elle habille
ortolo quelles sont les conditions pour
avoir droit en france aujourd'hui un
congé paternité alors elles sont un
petit peu compliqué administrativement
je pense pas que je vais tout vous les
êtes vous les citer il faut justifier
déjà être faut justifier de la naissance
de l'enfant ce qui est vraiment un
prérequis faut justifier du lien avec
l'enfant il faut pas nécessairement être
le père pour y avoir droit
on peut vivre maritalement avec la mère
et avoir le droit à ce congé on
bénéficie d'une aide est une adepte en
perçoit des indemnités journalières de
la caf qui sont la sécurité sociale
pendant qu'ils sont assez intéressantes
et on a un dossier à déposer faut
prévenir son employeur un mois la
pension que le salaire est bien
maintenue pour les papas qui prennent
leur congé paternité est que l'employeur
peut refuser un congé paternité partir
du moment où la demande est faite un
mois avant non alors jean mathieu 11
jours congé paternité en france c'est ce
que c'est suffisant pour accueillir
convenablement j'ai envie de dire à un
enfant
je crois que ce dépôt est éminemment de
la situation de chacun
on peut
ne pas s'arrêter de travailler
pratiquement y compris d'ailleurs les
mamans
et s'occuper de ses enfants c'est une
question d'organisation
donc je les aime au sein de votre
association vous seriez pour j'imagine
l'allongement du congé paternité
c'est à dire qu' on n'est pas contre
mais ce qu'on ce qu'on voudrait bien
savoir ce qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière
comme logique politique c'est quand même
assez politique parce qu'on a quand même
entendu dire que ce qu'une façon n'est
ce pas de deux pouces et un petit peu
les pères en avant sous entendus jusqu'à
présent il s'occuperait passer de leur
enfant et ainsi de suite
donc ça évidemment c'est quelque chose
qu'on récuse totalement
d'autant que nous notre thème je pense
qu'on va se développer un petit peu
c'est que on souhaite s'occuper de nos
enfants le plus possible la parité en
cas de séparation et pas seulement au
moment de la naissance ou plus ou peu de
temps après et ça c'est excessivement
difficile en france
moi j'ai pas de jeu pas d'avis sur le
sujet c'est effectivement chacun fait ce
qu'il veut ce que je vois c'est qu'il a
effectivement beaucoup de congés
différents tels congés naissance congés
paternité alors pour pâques ont congé
paternité congé parental aussi congé
parental qui a été réformé qui est
important aussi le congé parental c'est
celui que vous prenez vous cesser
complètement partiellement votre
activité
on a voulu on la réforme est aussi en
2015 pour inciter les pères à le prendre
plus fréquemment ça reste assez assez
mesuré je crois qu'il ya 4 % les hommes
on les passait a péniblement à 4 4%
et c'est là où il ya beaucoup
d'inégalités pour le coup qui se joue
c'est là où on a des des ruptures de
carrière qui sont assez importante chez
les femmes et on voit que ça n'a pas
fonctionné ça pas fonctionné parce que
le congé parental pour le coup est très
peu très peu indemnisées karman ont
donné aux yvelinois ce qu'il pensait
justement de la durée du congé paternité
les images sont signés manon varaldo oui
oui je trouve que c'est une très bonne
chose que le père s'occupe de l'enfant
mais oui c'est bien un je ne sais pas il
est à quinze jours la manoeuvre en ce
jour ouais moi il ya des pays où on fait
beaucoup plus à moi ce serait bien je
pense que ce sera mieux un petit peu
plus long pour aider madame ne serait-ce
que
pendant onze de plus dont jour 3 4
semaines mais là c'est pas à moi de
décider ce genre de choses mais je suis
je suis vraiment passionné qu'il
faudrait l'allongé répartition des rôles
entre les sexes c'est on va dire on
essaye d'être égalité donc on peut les
pères a peut-être un peu moins drôle au
début de la vie mais quand même ce
serait bien d'être appelé impliqué de
pouvoir voir plus d'égalité entre les
sexes ont ce jour c'est déjà beaucoup
ce serait bien parce que j'ai trois
garçons et ils ont été très occupés
quand ils ont eu leur enfant
donc je trouve ça intéressant qu'il
puisse partager dès le départ toutes les
tâches de la maman en tant que parent je
pense qu'il faudrait prendre exemple sur
les pays du nord par exemple
ben moi même je suis père de deux
enfants et j'aurais voulu participer
aussi aux à rester à la maison et du
quai un peu mes enfants et donc profité
de ce congé de paternité effectivement
une réaction par rapport à ce qu'on
vient d'entendre jean rède ciseaux c'est
assez flou tout ça ceci si la cie la
logique générale c'est que à supposer
qu'ils le fassent pas assez bien jusqu'à
présent
les pères ce que plus de leurs enfants
c'est pas une question de 11 jours
quinze jours trois semaines
c'est pendant toute la jeunesse sa fin
des enfants donc le
encore une fois ce sujet très délicat
décalé par rapport à d'abord à la
réalité en général et par rapport à
notre vocation de nos préoccupations qui
sont extrêmes
moi ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
quand on a vu notamment des des jeunes
est un jeu ne pas pas et je pense que
les attend cation changé je pense
qu'avant culturellement les hommes et
plus de mal à cesser leur activité pour
s'occuper de leurs jeunes enfants
je pense que les nouvelles générations
et à priori ça ressort à peu près dans
les sondages ont plus envie de ce temps
là au début c'est quand même important
le nitia pas que ça on est d'accord mais
c'est quand même important ces premiers
ses premiers moments avec son enfant
donc là on sont je pense qu'il ya des
changements un peu culturelles et des
attentes un peu différente là dessus
c'est simplement ça me parait que
positif faut pas forcer les gens mais
qui est cette possibilité là sinon mais
que que la possibilité s'élargissent
soit mieux compenser financièrement pour
ceux qui souhaitent absolument oui
question finances
le père aussi ne prennent pas peut-être
des congés paternité parce que des fois
notamment les indépendantes que du coup
il ya une baisse de 2,7 et c'est
exactement dans ce que je rappelais de
2014 de janvier 2014 il y avait des
associations de femmes qui d'une
certaine manière protester ou en tout
cas exprimé un grand scepticisme sur ce
qu'il disait mais alors comment va faire
la boulangère qu'on va faire le la femme
médecin et ainsi de suite voilà c
ça semble très difficile de parler en
toute logique de de parler de façon
normes et de cette question là alors que
ça s'applique à des populations d'une
extrême variété en partie
professionnellement et même
économiquement puisque après tout le
recours ou nounous ainsi de suite bon
ski quand même le préciser n'évite pas
de s'occuper de ses enfants le matin
avant de partir au travail le soir quand
on en revient ainsi de suite alors on
entendait un papa qui parlait justement
du du modèle nordique nordique pardon
vous propose justement de voir un petit
peu la situation chez nous chez nos
voisins européens
en suède par exemple les pères peuvent
bénéficier de 60 jours de congé
paternité payé je parle bien de te congé
paternité
cinquante quatre jours en finlande 20
jours en lituanie la france donc avec
onze jours et puis ben par contre 7 en
allemagne 1 que les papas si j'ose dire
sont les moins bien lotis puisqu'ils
n'existent pas encore de congé paternité
payé pourquoi finalement selon vous la
france ne prend elle pas exemple
finalement sur sur les pays
le modèle suédois ou les modèles
finlandais où les modèles aussi
norvégien d'envoi pas puisqu'on parle de
l'union européenne pourquoi du comment
je servais pas tellement vous dire mais
il ya quand même plein de choses parce
que fort fois jeté congé il ya congé
naissance congés paternité congé
parental qui est devenu mixte donc au
final on a quand même dû des
possibilités de prendre un congé assez
longue pour être avec son enfant donc
les moins rémunérés ça mais il est un
peu moins de 400 euros le congé parental
on est d'accord quel sajoo énormément
parce qu'on dit qu'il n'est pas très
bien congés payés congés paternité ça va
de 9 euros à 87 euros par jour par
rapport aux congés pour le coup
parentale ou je crois qu'il a 400 euros
par mois
il ya quand même une petite il ya quand
même une grosse différence
je suis pas sûr que les freins soit
complètement
économique je suis pas sûr sur quinze
jours ça fasse une grosse différence
ce que je voulais dire aussi tout à
l'heure et pour réagir sur micro
trottoir j'ai ya un monsieur qui très
gentiment disait qu'il fallait plus aidé
madame qu'il dérange un petit peu parce
qu'on parle pas mal de la répartition
des charges domestiques on parle pas mal
de la répartition du travail au niveau
de la famille et la charge mentale qui
montent pas mal dans les débats après je
t'en faire tout un tout un sujet mais au
plus on crée des occasions pour les
pères de trouver leur place rapidement
je pense que ça peut pas faire de mal
vous parlais justement la place du père
les modèles norvégien au suédois
justement semble mettre plus fin plus en
avant la place du père est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ces modèles justement
nordique
oui il faudrait s'inspirer
c'est le jeu je suis nous sommes
extrêmement d'accord sur la notion de
place du père et de d'équilibrer la
place du père mais pas uniquement
pendant quelques jours ou quelques
semaines à l'occasion de la naissance
des enfants
alors là je vais venir directement pour
peut-être paraître un peu abstrait pour
les téléspectateurs sur le sujet qui
nous préoccupe
il faut savoir que la moitié des couples
à peu près en france se sépare donc avec
des enfants mineurs et dans ce cas là un
père qui souhaite s'occuper
à parité tant de ses enfants selon la
formule juridique qui s'appelle
résidence alternée en france qui en
belle en belgique d'ailleurs porte un
nom encore plus clair ils sont pleins de
bon sens nos amis belges puisqu'il
appelle seul l'hébergement égalitaire et
bien en france quand un père souhaite la
résidence alternée une très belle étude
du ministère de la justice
papa déçoit pas à montrer la pop tant
que quand la mer est d'accord c'est
toujours accordé par le juge et quand
elle s'y oppose c'est presque tout le
temps refusé voilà dans quel système on
est louis en marche un petit peu sur la
tête par rapport à ces débats de savoir
si ces 11 jours quinze jours à la
naissance alors juste revenir en fait au
congé paternité juste pour parler des
entreprises en france est de plus en
plus d'entreprises malgré tout alors
c'est vrai vous parliez donc de pour
vous 11 jours qu'un jour ça ne peut pas
changer selon vous grand chose mais il
ya quand même des entreprises qui
mettent en place justement des congés
paternité plus long par exemple depuis
le 1er mars donc c'est tout récent les
salariés de l'oréal france peuvent
bénéficier d'un congé paternité de six
semaines
l'argument qui est mis en avant
saucisses et pour contribuer à une
meilleure égalité professionnelle aux
femmes sommes justement qu'est ce que
vous en pensez par rapport à par rapport
à cet argument je suis aussi pour
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes n'y a pas de sujet
là dessus encore une fois le problème de
base est il aisé pour moi tout vient des
écarts de salaire à un moment
appartements les hommes et les femmes
ont des écarts de salaires et des écarts
de responsabilité il ya des écarts en
termes de charge de travail aussi et
tant qu'on équilibrera pas mieux ces
sujets là on aura du mal derrière à
pouvoir mettre en place des choses qui
fonctionnent correctement
si on prend le congé parental pour y
revenir
c'est simple vous êtes face à la
situation de savoir qui prend le congé
parental avait quand même choisir la
personne en couple qui gagne un peu
moins pour les sacrifices financiers
soit moins importante avance et plus les
femmes on va pas se mentir qui gagne un
peu moins que monsieur est donc c'est un
choix au final je suis patient poser la
question qui a envie de le faire je suis
pas sûr qu'on serait à 90 à 96 % pour
des femmes et à 4% pour les hommes c'est
un plutôt un espèce de non choix
après je vous rejoins c'est pas ça qui
va changer la face du monde je suis suis
d'accord avec vous mais c'est par les
petits gestes des fois qu'on arrive à
qu'on arrive à trouver des solutions
et encore une fois au moment de la
naissance dès les premiers moments il ya
quand même des choses qui peuvent qui
peuvent se nouer et que les entreprises
anticipent et accord de plus je vois pas
ce qu'il ya de mal ou deux est-ce que
j'ai pas finalement rendre obligatoire
ce congé paternité moi c'est très clair
mal tout ce qui est obligatoire me
dérange fondamentalement donc oui je
crois que on est très gênée pour cerner
la véritable logique le véritable sens
de ce genre de questions alors on parle
de l'égalité des chances
professionnelles m'ont soit mais
finalement c'est
alors c'est pour lui c'est pour les
adultes et pour les enfants c'est pour
le lien entre les parents et les enfants
c'est c'est pourquoi la maman est obligé
de s'arrêter on va dire deux mois et
demi environ
après la naissance si elles souhaitent
reprendre une activité professionnelle
avant c'est un petit peu compliqué alors
que si par exemple le congé paternité
est allongé que monsieur prennent le
relais ça pourrait peut-être joue sur
quelques jours quelques semaines ou à
l'heure mais bon l'entreprise est
importante plus la femme a du mal à
retrouver son poste
c'est une autre question donc je crois
que là ça devient une question de droit
social il faut peut-être ce moment là
envisager des réglementations pour
s'assurer absolument que quel que soit
le temps pendant lequel le parent lors
souvent la femme et pourquoi pas l'homme
a quitté son travail à cause d'une d'une
naissance et bien qu'ils aient
absolument un contrôle une sûreté une
sécurité une garantie de retrouver son
niveau de poste son niveau de salaire
son rythme de 2 de progression de
carrière et ainsi de suite sans doute à
ce niveau là qui si on veut vraiment
traiter sérieusement cette question là
mon avis c'est comme ça qu'il faut
l'envisager
maintenant après si on dit non mais
c'est pas ce même pas pour les adultes
c'est fondamental pour le lien parent
enfant ce qu'on entend pas trop dire je
sais pas je parle souvent sous votre
contrôle mais non mais
sûrement enquêter alors soit à ce moment
là si c'est ça si c'est prouvé
il faut des lois qui obligent en effet
les deux parents à prendre telle ou
telle durée de congé parental et façon
équivalente l'avortement 70% c'est déjà
sans obliger sait déjà que ça fonctionne
ça correspond à un besoin une attente
juste un petit roman que vous disiez le
prendre après le congé maternité ou que
prendre le congé parental dans les
quatre mois suivant la naissance
vous êtes obligé de le prendre tout de
suite à la naissance peut être là pas là
où il ya nécessairement les besoins on
pouvait desquels un petit peu c'est bien
lors l'émission touche bientôt à sa fin
déjà on va commencer à conclure alors ce
qu'il faut allonger oui ou non le congé
paternité pour une meilleure égalité
homme-femme meilleure égalité
maman papa jean l'attiser écoutez nous
avez compris que nous sommes pour qu'ils
aient des des mesures fortes qui soient
prises en matière d'égalité parental
dans tous les domaines et pas seulement
dans les premières semaines de l'enfant
et pour la moitié des couples qui se
séparent que les pères soi est une
garantie d'égalité parentale en cas de
séparation ce qui n'est absolument pas
le cas allongé oui non le congé
paternité chez suis j'y suis favorable
tellement me demander mon avis mais
effectivement son principe j'y suis et
j'y suis favorable juste ont ils une
réforme qui a été adopté là qui va
permettre au 1er juillet de cette année
pas de prendre un mois supplémentaire de
congé parental quand l'enfant est
hospitalisé dans une unité de soins
spécialisés donc ce qui est là aussi
beau ce quinqua encore une fois
marginale mais frappe mais c'est
toujours un pas important c'est toujours
bon à prendre contre son enfant est
hospitalisé à la naissance
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir été présent se retrouvent
mercredi prochain pour un nouveau cette
unité pas
[Musique]